the Chinese tradition of our family it's
very strong everyone have to get married
and have child to chip on the emini
every family cannot accept a gay son so
you will feel guilty you will feel sad
for being gay
being a make my family feel sad so in
February I decided to try to go to the
training to accept the chamber it's a
big day today
the phoniest TV invite me an iron to
join the TV show talking about the
conversion therapy it's a very big deal
in China because the Chinese TV never
talking about this issue until financial
domination
what's hey
yeonggi
my friend called me iron and bisexual
queer I'm the director of a Beijing LGBT
Center
I might serve I read about my father's
family to save me on television because
I didn't came to I didn't come to come
out to my father
how could my family face the challenge
from the neighborhood I don't want my
family be hurt like many people
dispersing to LGBT people are people who
have some mental disease so in China we
still have this kind of Commerce and
therapy
the consultant in the clinic that he
hypnosis to me and he asked me to think
about the sense of having sex with with
men and then he neglected stop me
so we want to let people to know that
electric shock still exists and it hurt
our LGBT community
it took me a while to decide to seal the
clinic and I - I know there are many gay
people like me have that situation - PQ
and there are many clinic in China
we'll have to stop that this case could
tell the whole country in China and all
over the world how much they saw is not
easy but he needed a pitcher today I am
going to see my lawyer
who helped me to fill this case to clean
it up I do an old mentor what I do
Murphy doing that month which I have
made dana jamison jess was a coach and i
used by Machado
oh that was mr. hawk mm-hmm Savannah
senior will refer to the animal I don't
wanna quit Ian so please must enhance
idea what you're telling us a - I said
I'll see you ever Gillian s100 sound how
you the but no you got a loser
so she had shit there's a 29% in July
2009 for civilian official see he's
really on now stop and the yen's we're
be recorded in history yeah because this
is the first term LGBT people initiated
a scan on education so it's very
inspirational for LGBTQ community
I don't sing I'm ready because the
problem the situation is very that
someone have to stand out to stop this
because if we don't stand out of the
situation we'll both end was Canada we
both can now do long Ella
semester wha
I see
passing wave solutions Amma
Oh ciao Casanova
dude aha
oh wow now myself senior casa
the best result is the cause pronounced
commercial therapy is illegal
very important the results it changed
the people smile and we can use to lose
how to tell everybody there especially
tell the parents in China gay cannot be
changed
you